a hora foguete embora foguetinho
ou tiver com um ponto dois eu tiro só
modelo
e
agora tá com r$ 130
eu peço um diabo desse jeito é
G1
Oi boa tarde
só esse
faço agora ela somente né
Tu
acha que eu ia te irrita que você não
tem nada a ver a gente tá com pa para a
irmandade é minha sobrinha Renata me
chama a galera quebrar é
assim né
falo com você tá é
e pega no freezer depois a gente a gente
96 97 99 7
9090 da botou na até o nome da feio lá
sentei não Guerreiro vou lá ver você aí
não só pegar a bolsa aqui com por favor
e já já só vez
a 15 né isso e o seu nome é Eva é
preciso do nome para botar crédito e
[Aplausos]
e é pegar a mão molhada mas ninguém
nunca chamou você para ir renomear os
animais ali né que eu acho que eu devo
não dá para os animais que não parece
tipo ornitorrinco
eu poderia chamar com o Leandro que eu
acho que ele
eu acho que ele pouquinho espinho vão
ficar Inconveniente deixa eu eu acho que
ele for inscrito eu não muito bem né
porque ninguém vai querer passar a mão
Esse é o dela tá bom
o meu celular tá faltando Tá bom agora
não que a mensagem ainda não
vou passar o seu um
e não
e para onde
a caixinha festinha e o pacote de gelo
mesmo cada mulher que está levando gelo
saiu aqui não essa água aí você você
pode você pode botar aqui no chão não de
dormir
dormir bem você tá segurando uma mão e
outro no outro Isso é do lip
sempre eu terminar minha conversa do
almoço aqui por favor abre aqui tem que
entregar isso aí pronto
toda hora você
tem que ir hoje de noite vai ter uma
festinha lá
tu vai ver
quem faz mais
isso não viu
que
as pessoas
que você gosta e
a festa é
Oi
e eu tava querendo levar um só hoje vai
leva o que tu gosta mais
eu já vou aí tá bom
vou levar vou levar o leitinho
o tipo de pessoa
eu tenho estudo
e o Mateus mano Eita que essa festa vai
gerar eu hoje o patrão se ela vai me
responder nesse instante que eu vou ter
que encerrar de crédito no celular dela
o prejuízo de DC desta mercearia se for
ficar saindo sem pagar mais elevado
somente o pago
18 e 50 que eu já tô comendo o que eu
não podia comer o que eu não é
E aí
o
arco 12 disse que eu como hoje é
o hino louco perdi num foguete
8:50 do negócio e oito desse
a marca já chega chega tá empoeirada e
O
que conta vou fazer o povo que entro mas
é pagar a
E aí
[Risadas]
[Música]
E aí
[Aplausos]